[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas la guerra en ucrania
podría durar años esto que ha afirmado
recientemente el secretario general de
la otan los combates siguen en el este
del país donde las tropas rusas
controlan poco a poco más territorio con
el objetivo de hacerse con el control
total de la región del donbass al
noroeste de la capital kiev
específicamente en lucha fue descubierta
una nueva fosa común la policía dice que
los cuerpos muestran signos de tortura y
el equipo de france 24 estuvo ahí para
la exhumación
en el bosque a 10 km de butch a la
tierra recién excavada indica un
descubrimiento siniestro
la prensa mundial ha sido convocada al
desentierro de otra fosa común
son los cuerpos de siete hombres
descubiertos cuando los combatientes
voluntarios que patrullaban vieron dedos
que sobresalían del suelo
después de ser exhumados los cuerpos
serán examinados por los equipos
forenses que investigan los crímenes de
guerra
el jefe de policía de kiev apunta que
los primeros indicios señalan que las
víctimas fueron ejecutadas de un tiro en
la cabeza por las tropas rusas esta
primavera
les dispararon en las rodillas lo que
nos indica que fueron torturados les
ataron las manos a la espalda con cinta
adhesiva lo que indica que estas
personas fueron retenidas durante
bastante tiempo y que intentaron
sacarles alguna información formal hasta
ahora se han descubierto más de 1.300
cadáveres en la región de kiev cientos
de personas siguen desaparecidas ya que
las búsquedas se ralentizan por las
minas terrestres en la zona
creo que se necesitarán varios años para
retirar todos los cadáveres de la región
de kiev porque el enemigo se ensaña
secuestrando incluso civiles solitarios
sobre los que no tenemos ninguna
información proyectadas una semilla con
armas las tropas rusas acamparon en
estos bosques cuando intentaban tomar la
capital y ahora un enterrador local
siguió trabajando un tiempo durante la
ocupación rusa
aparecían cadáveres en las calles
alguien nos llamaba cuando la gente veía
un cadáver todos los lugareños nos
conocían decían han matado a alguien lo
traeremos aquí por favor vengan a
enterrarlo así que si podíamos cogíamos
un ataúd recogíamos el cuerpo y lo
enterramos en el cementerio dos meses
después de la retirada de los rusos los
bosques de los alrededores de kiev
siguen siendo testigos de la brutalidad
y los horrores de la guerra siguen
saliendo a la luz
el conflicto ucraniano ha desatado
temores de que se genere una crisis
alimentaria a gran escala esto como
consecuencia del bloqueo de los puertos
ucranianos en el mar negro donde se
aglomeran millones y millones de
toneladas de cereales que no pueden ser
exportados algo que ha llegado a ser
tildado de crimen de guerra por parte de
las autoridades europeas a pesar de que
rusia niegue toda responsabilidad en
este hecho pero la crisis de la
seguridad alimentaria se vive también
lejos de ahí en perú la organización de
naciones unidas para la alimentación y
la agricultura fao advierte que el 51%
de la población está en riesgo de
enfrentar una pues 1 de cada 4 peruanos
no cuenta con lo suficiente para cubrir
los gastos de su canasta básica la
información nos la trae nuestro
corresponsable francisco zacarías
marina ramírez es desempleada y madre
soltera la falta de recursos le ha
llevado a valerse de ayudas sociales
como la olla común para alimentar a sus
cuatro hijos y más que todo porque todo
está caro y porque no alcanza porque a
veces no hay trabajo toda su vida toda
su vida y no hay trabajo por las
circunstancias del gobierno lo que está
mal en lo que vivimos en perú más de 8
millones de personas viven en situación
de pobreza y más de un millón son pobres
extremos según el instituto nacional de
estadística
4000 ollas comunes creadas por mujeres
son el único paliativo que tienen los
más necesitados para alimentarse en
estos momentos sin embargo está en el
riesgo de cerrar porque no reciben
recursos ante la crisis el gobierno
evalúa entregar un bono de más de 324
millones de dólares medida que es
criticada por diversos economistas lo
que debería hacer el gobierno más bien
es ayudar a las áreas comunes abastecer
con productos a las ollas comunes cosas
que hasta el momento no ha hecho o sea
olímpicamente hay 2600 ollas comunes que
están
abandonadas que no tienen atención
sistemática por parte del gobierno
orfa esteban vive un doble drama además
de batallar para que la olla común que
dirige no cierre por falta de alimentos
también tiene que luchar por sanar a su
hijo que forma parte del 38 por ciento
de los niños peruanos que sufren de
anemia me siento triste por lo que mi
niñez me está así bajo peso y ahí están
bien igual que están igual bueno y son
más más chiquitos también me había común
así como marina y orf a otros 15
millones de peruanos no pueden comer
tres veces al día bien un 11.5 por
ciento de niñas y niños menores de 5
años están en situación de desnutrición
crónica
pero no se escapa la crisis alimentaria
mundial que ya está afectando a toda
latinoamérica
eeuu alcanzará muy pronto la cifra de 95
mil refugiados afganos que recientemente
entraron al país después de que los
talibanes tomaran el total control de
kabul en agosto de 2021 su situación ha
pasado a un segundo plano desde el
comienzo de la crisis ucraniana y entre
esos refugiados hay muchos antiguos
combatientes que fueron entrenados por
estadounidenses y cuya vida se hizo
sencillamente imposible en afganistán
después de que washington decidiera
retirar a sus soldados para ellos fue un
viaje sin retorno el siguiente es un
informe de máxima
sami llegó a estados unidos hace 8 meses
este es un té afgano que me trajo un
amigo desde afganistán
este ex oficial de las fuerzas
especiales afganas sólo pudo rescatar
este traje tradicional pastún
algunos recuerdos de su vida militar
y fotos
este es mi padre y este es un amigo muy
cercano pero también mi jefe y el jefe
del estado mayor del ejército el general
a meta
pero sã me salvó lo más importante
su hijo de 2 años su mujer y su hermana
todos condenados a muerte por los
talibanes ha conseguido cambiarse de
ropa después de un par de semanas
un piso prestado por el estado de
maryland
y un trabajo en un restaurante de
washington un buen comienzo para una
nueva vida gracias a joseph y él también
es un refugiado afgano que llegó a eeuu
en la década de 1980 durante la guerra
contra los soviéticos
qué consejo puede darle trabajar duro al
final dará sus frutos a una nueva vida
pero una que es a mí claramente no
eligió
un mensaje más es un amigo que me
pregunta cómo puede salir de afganistán
pero no puedo hacer nada por él y eso
que me ruega que lo ayude
y este soy yo
echo mucho de menos mi uniforme mi
equipo y mi fusil
sabéis que es muy difícil para un
soldado dejar sus armas y sus hombres
y
tengo tres títulos uno en ciencias
políticas otro en farmacia y mi título
de militar
pero hoy no soy nada
somos refugiados
solo en washington hay miles de personas
como sham y miles de personas que tienen
que reinventar sus vidas aquí en esta
américa que no conocen sobre todo
después de haber llorado la pérdida
definitiva de un afganistán democrático
la semana pasada se conmemoró el
aniversario número 40 del fin de la
guerra de las malvinas o pop dance como
se les conoce en inglés una guerra que
dejó más de 900 muertos en 72 días de
confrontación y que se selló con la
victoria de londres algunos de los
veteranos británicos compartieron con
france24 las grandes lecciones
aprendidas en este conflicto con
argentina el siguiente es un informe de
luisa pulido y david lópez
hace 40 años tome cris lucharon en la
misma guerra hoy los une una larga
amistad y la misma familia de veteranos
en ese entonces gris su oficial de la
armada navegaba el hecho meses coventry
mientras se entrenaban gibraltar su
barco duró una semana en llegar a aguas
del atlántico sur y el 25 de mayo de
1982 la embarcación fundida tras ser
impactada con tres bombas morón witch
una de las cuales me causa un daño grave
el 27 por ciento de mi cuerpo se quemó
pude salir del barco y lamentablemente
19 de mis compañeros fallecieron ese día
mientras que toma sargento del ejército
cruzó a pie las islas durante una semana
el terreno es bastante inhóspito el
clima es duro era invierno el suelo
estaba húmedo y pantanoso y consiste en
muchos montículos de rocas que no puedes
cruzar no importa lo que hagas tienes
que rodear a naranjos
el 14 de junio de 1982 el último día de
la guerra son recuerda que inicialmente
fue un día más de combate
era euforia pero también tristeza porque
sabíamos que algunos de nuestros
camaradas no habían visto ese día era un
costo y nunca nunca se recuperaría
pero chris no tiene memoria de ese día
estaba luchando por su vida en un
hospital de montevideo pero una
reflexión ha permanecido intacta desde
entonces sabe y es para mí la guerra y
el conflicto son algo terrible y se debe
hacer todo lo posible para evitar un
conflicto abierto has visto lo que está
pasando en ucrania en este momento
los dos han regresado a las islas en
diferentes aniversarios mientras que
otros veteranos han vuelto por su salud
mental
algunas personas necesitan que sus
fantasmas descansen algunas personas que
quieran regresar y ver donde perdieron a
sus camaradas y recordarlos
correctamente
'el nacional' armin y siempre salta en
una exposición la valentía de los
veteranos y también la transformación
para los isleños
la guerra fue increíble para las islas
falkland al ser casi olvidadas por el
gobierno británico se volvieron muy
importante para asegurarse de que se
escucharan las voces de la gente en este
aniversario también recuerda que de una
guerra tan dura sigue la disputa sobre
la soberanía de las islas
gracias por seguir una nueva emisión de
corresponsables nos damos cita la
próxima semana sigue con más información
en france 24 224 puntocom